uh i got to ask you at a few different
attempts at the theory of everything
especially recently uh so
i've been
for many years a big fan of cellular
automata of complex systems and
obviously if because of that a fan of
stephen wolfram's work on in that space
but he's recently been talking about a
theory
of everything through his physics
project essentially
uh what do you think about this kind of
discrete
theory of everything for like from
simple rules and simple objects on
hypergraphs emerges all of our reality
where time and space are emergent
basically everything we see around us is
immersed
yeah i have to say unfortunately i have
kind of pretty much zero sympathy for
that i mean i don't um
i spend a little time looking at it and
i just don't see
it doesn't seem to me to get anywhere
and and it really is just really really
doesn't agree at all with what what with
what i'm seeing this the kind of
unification of math and physics that i'm
kind of talking about around certain
kinds of very deep ideas about geometry
and stuff this
if you want to believe that
that your things are really coming out
of cellular automata at the most
fundamental level you have to believe
that
everything that i've
seen my whole career and as
as beautiful powerful ideas that that's
all just kind of a mirage which just
kind of randomly is emerging from these
more basic very very simple-minded
things and
i
you have to give me some serious
evidence for that and i'm saying nothing
so mirage you don't think there could be
a consistency
where
things like quantum mechanics
could emerge from much much much smaller
discrete
like computational type systems i think
from the point of view of a certain
mathematical point of view quantum
mechanics is already
mathematically as simple as it gets it
really is
a story about really
the fundamental objects that you work
within when you write down a quantum
theory are in some in some point of view
precisely the fundamental objects
at this deepest levels of mathematics
you're working with they're exactly the
same
so
and cellular automata are something
completely different which don't fit
into these structures and so i just
don't see why anyway i don't see it as a
promising
uh
you know promising thing to do and then
just looking at it and seeing does this
go anywhere does this solve any problem
that i've ever
that i didn't does this solve any
problem of any kind i just don't see it
yeah to me cellular automata and these
hypergraphs
i'm not sure solving a problem
is even the standard to apply here at
this moment
to me
the fascinating thing is that the
question it asks have no good answers so
there's not good math explaining forget
the physics of it math explaining the
behavior of complex systems yeah and
that to me is
both exciting and paralyzing like we're
at very early days of understanding
you know
how complicated and fascinating things
emerge from simple rules yeah you know i
agree i think that is a
truly great problem and depending where
it goes it may be um
you know
it may start to develop some kind of
connections to the
the things that i've kind of found more
fruitful and
hard to know just i think
a lot of that area i i kind of strongly
feel
best
not say too much about it because i just
i don't know too much about it and uh i
mean again we're back to this original
problem that you know your time in life
is uh
is limited you have to figure out what
you're going to spend your time thinking
about and that that's something i just
never seen enough to convince me to
spend more time thinking about well also
timing it's not just that our time is
limited but uh the timing of the kind of
things you think about there there's
some
aspect to cellular automata these kinds
of objects that it feels like
we're very many years away from
having big breakthroughs on
and so it's like you have to pick the
problems that are solvable today in fact
my intuition
again not perhaps biased is it feels
like the kind of systems that
complex systems that cellular automata
are
would not be solved by human brains
it feels like well like it feels like
something post-human that will solve
that problem or like significantly
enhance humans meaning like using
computational tools
very powerful computational tools
to us to to crack these problems open
um that's that's if our
approach to science our ability to
understand science our ability to
understand physics will become more and
more computational or there'll be a
whole field that's computational nature
which currently is not the case that
currently computation is the thing that
sort of
assists us
in um
understanding science the way we've been
doing it all along but if there's a
whole new i mean that world from new
kind of science right it's a little bit
dramatic but you know
this
if computers could do science on their
own computational systems
perhaps
that's the way they would do the science
they would try to understand the
cellular automata and that feels like
we're decades away so
uh perhaps it'll crack open some
interesting facets of this physics
problem but it's it's very far away so
timing is everything that that's
perfectly possible
you